hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast factors that influence
label accuracy who's to blame
presented by Katherine Layton a senior
technical applications chemist at waters
corporation
I'm Judy I work of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's events we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth
labyrinth is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before I begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want to anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen well answer as
many questions is we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located any promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
Katherine Leighton I will now turn the
presentation over to her thank you for
the introduction Judy today I'm going to
be speaking to a broad knowledge based I
will be speaking to consumers for
cannabis products I will be speaking to
producers of cannabis products and I
will also be speaking to scientists who
are testing cannabis products in the
laboratory because of this broad
knowledge base it's important that we
all start off on the same page so I'm
going to provide a brief introduction to
cannabis testing in general here in the
United States we have federal regulatory
agencies that monitor the foods and
drugs four that are manufactured and
distributed to to consumers those
regulatory
agencies are the Food and Drug
Administration and the USDA the Food and
Drug Administration is responsible for
monitoring food drugs dietary
supplements vaccines medical devices and
tobacco products USDA is responsible for
monitoring meat vegetables and also
giving an organic certification to
organic products the situation is
slightly different for cannabinoid
products cannabinoid products are
monitored and regulated at the state
level with 50 different states we have
potentially 50 different regulations for
these products some states have very
high regulations and some states have no
regulation at all for the past several
years many studies have been performed
showing problems that we have with
labeling accuracy of these cannabis
products one of the most recent studies
was published in November of 2017 this
study was published by the Journal of
the American Medical Association in this
study they looked at CBD extracts that
were sold online they took a look at CBD
supplements they took a look at CBD
teachers and also they looked at CBD
vapor oils and they found in this study
that 70% of the samples that they tested
listed incorrect potency on the
packaging label and surprisingly 20% of
the samples that they tested contained
the psychoactive compound the
psychoactive cannabinoid THC and THC was
not indicated on these CBD labels at all
if you look at the graph on the right
hand side you'll see that 43% of the
products contained more CBD than the
packaging label claimed then you may
think what's the big deal and having
more CBD in that product well that means
that the producers sold that product at
a financial loss they could
asked more money for that product if we
look in the plot we can see that 26% of
those products contained less CBD in the
product than than the packaging label
that means consumers probably paid more
money than that for that product than
they should have
potency testing for cannabinoid products
occurs at different stages this is an
example of what's required by the state
of Oregon the raw material is tested for
potency extracts are tested for potency
and infused products such as edibles
beverages and lotions are tested for
potency there are several different ways
cannabinoid products can be tested for
potency one way is using thin layer
chromatography which is also called TLC
this is a very fast easy and inexpensive
way to test for cannabinoids but
unfortunately it's not quantitative
meaning it does not give you an exact
result it gives you an estimate if we
look at the diagram below I will explain
how this testing is done the sample is
prepared by dissolving it in a solution
that sample is dropped or spotted on a
and absorbent matrix as the sample
passes through that absorbent matrix the
different cannabinoids are separated a
dye is added to the absorbent matrix and
we can visualize or estimate how much
cannabinoids we have in that product now
you can see on the right-hand side of
this diagram that it's very difficult to
distinguish the intensity of a 20% THC
containing compound and a 10 percent THC
compound so therein lies our problem
with THC all right with TLC testing gas
chromatography can also be used to test
for cannabinoid content gas
chromatography gives us an idea of the
total cannabinoid content but it cannot
be used to detect the acidic
and the reason for that is the sample is
heated in the gas chromatography
injector and when the sample is heated
the acidic cannabinoids are converted
into the neutral form therefore we are
only able to detect the neutral
cannabinoids using gas chromatography or
GC a gold standard for testing for
cannabinoid potency is high pressure
liquid chromatography it's also called
high-performance liquid chromatography
an HPLC the sample is dissolved so that
all the cannabinoids are pulled out of
the solid matrix the sample is injected
into a tube and the tube contains a
sand-like matrix the sand-like matrix
contains a may be a matrix like material
that has a different affinity towards
each of the cannabinoids some
cannabinoids will pass very quickly
through that sand-like matrix and some
cannabinoids will pass very slowly
through that connect through that
sand-like matrix after the cannabinoids
pass through the column they are they
are read by a detector the detector can
read the mass of the cannabinoid or it
can read the ultraviolet UV profile of
the cannabinoid on the right hand side
we see a chromatogram and in a
chromatogram time verses the detector
response is plotted the time allows us
to identify the cannabinoids based upon
how long the cannabinoids stayed in that
HPLC column and the detector response
allows us to quantify this cannabinoids
the most typical cannabinoids that we
test for are cannabidiol
tetrahydrocannabinol and kind of banal
this is an example of a chromatogram
where we've separated standard solutions
this is the first step in quantifying
cannabinoids when we separate standard
solutions it
allows us to know how long those
standards or how long those cannabinoids
stay in that HPLC column we can see from
this plot that the acidic cannabinoids
aleut first they allude between 1 and 2
minutes so we have seen EDA we have see
BGA and we have THC a the neutral
cannabinoids aleut after 3 minutes when
we inject our sample material we can
easily identify our cannabinoids of
interest and we see from this injection
of raw material we have a lot of THC a
and we have a little bit of CBN and
Delta 9 THC HPLC instruments come in
different shapes and sizes depending on
the manufacturer these are some of my
favorite HPLC instruments they're very
very accurate and they're also used in
highly regular regulated environments
such as the pharmaceutical environment
so now we get to the heart of this
presentation and we need to answer the
question what is causing label
inaccuracies for cannabis products the
accuracy of the label claim on a
cannabis product is dependent upon the
amount of error incurred during the
testing process error by definition is
the difference between the true result
and the measured result and we encounter
error that is pre-analytical meaning
error that occurred during sampling we
encounter error while the sample is
being tested and we also encounter error
post analytically or after the results
are generated and there will always be
some degree of error error will never go
away
it can only be minimized when we are
sampling the goal is to provide a sample
to the testing laboratory that
accurately represents the total
production batch we need to consider the
physical form of the sample if the
sample is a solid that material may need
to be ground or if it's a liquid that
may need to be homogenized
we need to think about the quantity of
the sample so that the the sample needs
to be statistically representative of
the overall batch or the large-scale
batch we also need to think about the
timing and frequency that the sample is
pulled typically critical batches are
tested or at any point in which the
sample will be sold directly to the
consumer or the batch will be sold to
the consumer
we need to collect samples and have them
tested it is very important to have a
written sampling procedure this
procedure needs to to inform the sampler
on when how and where that sample will
be pulled it needs to give instructions
on the storage and transport of the
sample what kind of analysis required
what happens to the results would the
acceptance criteria are for the results
and also what happens to the retention
samples the sample needs to be tested
for some reason we may need access to it
on the sample itself the name of the
sample the time the person who sampled
it method location and also the notebook
reference those are important things to
include on the sample itself and the
sampling procedure reduces error because
it allows the production facility to
trace their steps
it's a repeatable process everything is
documented and it also provides an
ability and ability to statistically
analyze the batch and get an idea of
what the ranges are for that particular
batch some states do have sampling
protocols and some states do not if you
are working in a state that does not
have a sampling protocol I encourage you
to research some of the states that do
and adopt those protocols and the reason
for that is some states are moving along
faster in this industry than others so
if you are proactive and you adopt one
of these sampling plans you will be
farther ahead of other producers
one thing that we need to remember when
we're sampling natural products is that
natural products have natural
heterogeneity cannabinoid production is
influenced by the strain of the cannabis
plant by the soil quality the light
intensity water humidity in the air and
the time of harvest or the age of the
plant so these are all variables that go
into how much cannabinoids are how many
cannabinoids that plant is producing in
order to minimize variability producers
can grow their product in a greenhouse
where they can tightly control the
environment they can also graft plants
or grow by propagation versus growing by
seedlings or they can also avoid cherry
picking and now that that's a very
important topic that I shouldn't you
mention when a product is being sampled
in the greenhouse or outdoors it is not
a good idea to select the plant with the
nicest the nicest trichomes or the best
looking plant or the the tallest plant
but what you really want to do is to
collect samples from plants that very
you may collect your nicest plant you
may collect your plant that's average
and you may collect the lowest plant and
homogenize those samples so that you get
an idea of the entire batch not just
what your best plant looks like in that
batch when we're talking about extracts
and final products we need to remember
that cannabinoids are soluble and fats
oils and alcohols they are not soluble
in water because of that mixing can be
dairy very difficult depending upon the
product that's being produced if we're
producing a solid product like a candy
bar typically those are tested using a
quartering method and that will give an
idea of what whether the mixing was
efficient or not
and according quartering method means
that you take one piece of the candy bar
on one side and another piece of a candy
bar on the other
side and test those individually and
that will give an i us an idea of
whether or not that product has been
mixed adequately it's very important to
remember the degradation starts
immediately so after a samples pulled it
will begin to degrade the plots that I'm
showing here are from a study done with
cannabis oil in this study they looked
at the concentration of Delta 9 THC and
CBD and they found that even when the
sample was stored in the refrigerator
there was degradation going on so even
at 6 months the concentration of THC
fell and the concentration of CBD fell
we were curious about how susceptible
some of these formulations were to
degradation so we decided to perform a
forest degradation study in our
laboratory for degradation studies are
used quite often in the pharmaceutical
environment in order to elucidate the
degradation pathways for the active
ingredient they are also used to
investigate the stability indicating
power of the analytical methods it's
important to know whether or not your
method will see degradation products
when they do show up so in our
laboratory we exposed a cannabinoid
tincture or a CBD ginger to to heat to
acid to base and also to hydrogen
peroxide in order to determine if it
would provide any sort of degradation of
that that sample this is a chromatogram
of the control so no stresses were
applied to the sample and we see a nice
sharp CBD peak and we added acid to the
CBD sample or CBD teacher we found the
Festiva tea converted to delta 9 and
delta 8 THC so this may be the reason
that some of those products that were
tested
in the the Journal of the American
Medical Association study contain THC
because the sample was not stable but
the product is not stable over time but
we've talked about pre-analytical error
or error that can occur during sampling
now we're going to talk about analytical
error and this is Error that occurs
during sample testing we need to think
about the materials that are used during
testing we need to think about the
methodology that is used during testing
we also need to think about instrument
and analyst accuracy now I mentioned
when I was talking about chromatograms
that typically we run a set of reference
standards and a reference standard is a
highly purified material that is used to
identify and quantify samples within
within a sample quantify compounds
within a sample in the pharmaceutical
industry reference standards are
typically kept as isolates or solids and
prepared in solution prior to sample
testing I mean the reason for that is
stability you don't want your reference
data to be degraded when you are testing
your samples so here in the United
States all cannabinoid isolates are
classified as schedule 1 controlled
substances which means that cannabis
testing laboratories must have a DEA
license in order to obtain cannabinoid
isolates and and many of these testing
laboratories do not so sanction DEA
exemptions are granted to manufacturers
of reference standard preparations
intended for laboratory use testing
laboratories rely upon the accuracy of
the CMA provided by the manufacturer for
these solutions so for some reason the
CFA did not accurately reflect the
concentration of the solution in the
ampule and the standard solution ampule
it would throw off all of the results
for the samples that they tested using
that solution so one thing I should
mention here is that since cannabinoids
our only soluble and alcohols most
reference stators or all reference
standards are typically prepared and
100% solvent we were curious to see how
accurate some of these reference
standards were in comparison to the CFA
so we were working with the laboratory
that does have a DEA license so they
were able to access cannabinoid
reference standards in the isolate or
solid form we injected the the standard
solutions for CBD that were prepared by
three manufacturers and we compared the
concentration result to the
concentration listed in the CMA for that
standard and we found that for the CBD
products or the CBD standards we tested
in all cases the concentration generated
in our laboratory was the same as what
was produced on the CMA but the case was
slightly different for Delta 9 THC we
found that one of those manufacturers
there see of aid didn't match the
concentration we were calculating in our
laboratory and the reason for that is if
you're analyzing are you performing
assay using two different
chromatographic methods it's possible
that one method will have a better
separation of the impurities from the
analyte of interest so the moral of the
story is it's important for cannabis
testing laboratories to to have an
incoming reference standard
qualification procedure and within this
procedure it's important to compare the
concentration on the CMA to the
concentration generated in their
laboratory to ensure that those two
things match with these reference data
materials it is important to handle the
solutions properly now these are highly
volatile solutions
they are prepared insolvent so the
solvent tends to evaporate and we found
that testing laboratories spend a lot of
money on these cannabinoid solutions but
the the they skimp on the materials so
they skimp on how they store these
solutions you can see in the photograph
here that the testing laboratory was
using a reference standard with a
punctured septum which means that that
reference standard was evaporating over
time if they had used a an HPLC vial
with a self-sealing septum it would have
kept that reference standard stable over
time so the moral of the story is don't
skimp on the quality of the materials
that are used after these these
expensive reference standards have been
purchased another observation that we've
made is that many testing laboratories
are using air displacement pipettes air
displacement pipettes are calibrated
with water and the cannabinoid reference
standards are prepared in solvent air
displacement pipettes work by producing
an airspace or using in a measured air
space between the top of the liquid
being pipetted and the piston of the
pipette now anytime we change from a an
aqueous solution or a pipetting of water
to a solvent solution we impact that
airspace we impact the calibration so we
found that it was very very difficult or
nearly impossible to produce a linear
curve or a linear standard curve
calibration curve using an air
displacement pipette the correct pipette
to use with these cannabinoid reference
standards would be a positive
displacement syringe pipette or a glass
pipette and this pipette eliminates that
airspace it eliminates the problems that
we see with
volatility of these solvent based
solutions and with the air displacement
pipette or glass pipette calibration
curves are quite linear and easier to
produce anytime we're working in
laboratory
we need to validate the chromatographic
methods that we're using a validation
ensures that the method works and it
works accurately in consistency there
are specific criteria for method
validation the method needs to be
specific for the material or compound of
interest that you're looking for it
needs to be linear and that means that
the method needs to be proportional to
the actual amount amount of the compound
present also the method needs to be
accurate so the difference between the
measured value and the real value needs
to be equal and also the method needs to
be precise meaning there's agreement
from multiple measurements of the same
sample and also the method needs to have
an accurate limit of detection so we
need to know how much or how low we can
go what's the lowest amount we can
detect with that method using using
chromatography so to reduce error it's
important to validate methods after any
changes in product formulation or
manufacturing of a product there are
several places we can go to get
information on method validation there
are some guidelines provided by the FDA
and there are also guidelines provided
by the International Committee on
harmonization and you see those two
documents here an example of a valid
method is a method that was recently
published in the journal as liquid
chromatography and related science
Sciences and in
method we were looking at the assay
determination for CB d there's been a
lot of talk lately regarding
standardized methods and standardized
methods are methods that have been
validated these are methods that have
been peer-reviewed and the results have
been compared between multiple labs
multiple instruments and multiple
analysts and standardized method by
definition is a method that's used
regularly by several labs over an
extended period of time
so these methods are tried-and-true
there's several years of experience
using the method and we know that they
work so where can you find a
standardized method well you can go to
the American herbal pharmacopoeia in the
American Herbal pharmacopoeia they have
an HPLC method for determination of
major phyto cannabinoids and cannabis it
gives you sample preparation procedures
there's one for crude cannabis there's
one for cannabis resin and cannabis oil
we see the ranges that can be tested
using this method we see the
chromatographic parameters and also the
calculations for that method are
provided so there are standardized
methods out there we just easy to go
where to look so why wouldn't you use a
standardized method well if you're using
if you have a formulation that causes an
interference and the chromatography for
the cannabinoids of interest you
probably want to create your own
chromatographic method you may want to
create your own method if you're looking
at impurities and you're trying to
identify contaminants also you may want
to create your own method if you are
investigating or trying to problem solve
some of those standardized methods may
not separate the peaks of interest that
you think that you want to look at so
feel free to develop your own separate
methods but make sure they work as
intended by validating those methods
whatever method you're using it is
important to perform a proficiency test
the Emerald test is one of the most
common proficiency tests and in this
test several laboratories are sent the
same sample and they test those samples
and send the information back to to the
Emerald company and the results are
statistically process for each
laboratory so the the laboratory can see
how accurate are they are how precise
they are compared to other laboratories
and this proficiency test is required by
some states for for laboratories to
maintain there are cannabis testing
accreditations you can also perform an
inter lab proficiency test so that's a
lab that's a test that that is done
within the laboratory so an inter lab
proficiency test would be using an
orthogonal method so you know Thugga no
method would be a method that uses
ultimate chromatographic selectivity
from the primary method some examples of
our THOG '''l methods would be methods
that operate at different PHS so if your
primary method performs a separation at
pH 10 you can have an orthogonal method
that does this that performs a
separation of each two same thing with
stationary phases you can change the
stationary phase and still perform
reverse phase chromatography and compare
the results you can also change the
chromatographic platform you may test
your sample by reverse phase you may
test your sample by SFC but as long as
you get the same result with those two
orthogonal methods you know that your
primary method is working properly we're
going to show you an example of how we
used an orthogonal method orthogonal
methodology we separated our reference
stand
using a pH 10 and we had an hemp extract
sample at one of our partnering
laboratories and when this happen
extract sample was tested we can see
based upon the retention time what our
cannabinoids are but we had one unknown
compound alluding in the chromatography
for the hemp extract we were able to
gain information by using in our thaw
Gadol method so we perform the
separation using the same column at pH 3
and we saw that the neutral cannabinoids
were not affected by the change in pH
but we found that the acidic
cannabinoids were affected by the change
in pH so we were able to gain
information on this unknown compound and
we know that it's likely an acidic
cannabinoid because it was affected by
the change in pH so essentially a
thought argA no methodology can help you
gain additional information on the
sample that you're testing there are so
four different ways to test cannabis
which I'm which I mentioned earlier in
the laboratory some some ways to test
cannabis are more accurate than others
you can use detection kits there are
also many portable devices on the
markets on the market and there's also
there are several HPLC instruments on
the market the most accurate way to test
your potency of canvas would be by HPLC
and that's because the variability is
very very low and not testing limits
also tried-and-true and used repeatedly
in the pharmaceutical environment if you
are a consumer and you're curious about
the products that you've purchased and
you want to get an idea of the
cannabinoid content then a detection kit
or a portable device is the best way to
go in the state testing regulations I
often see a regulation stating that
testing laboratories should have
qualified analyst
son staff so what is a qualified analyst
well it it means that the analyst has is
educated and it's also in in science or
in analytical testing but it also means
that that analyst has experience working
in a laboratory and the more experience
that analyst has working in a laboratory
the less likely that mistakes will
happen when I talk about mistakes in the
laboratory because we're all human
anything can happen
there are documentation errors that can
occur errors in technique calculation
errors and also we've seen contaminated
glassware being an issue and some
testing laboratories so the more
experience and training that an analyst
has the more likely the errors will be
caught and corrected early so this is
where we get to the fun stuff we've
talked about the pre-analytical error
which is the area that occurs in
sampling we've talked about analytical
error which occurs in laboratory and
we've also and now we're going to talk
about post analytical error and this is
where we get into result tempering and
lab shopping this this is probably the
worst error of them all a problem that
we've seen is that manufacturers know
that consumers tend to equate
cannabinoid product levels with price so
if a manufacturer produces a product
with very high cannabinoid levels they
will demand a higher price for it and
because of that there have been issues
with cutting and pasting on these
certificates of analysis we've also seen
lab shopping occur where a producer will
send out their sample to four different
testing laboratories and the laboratory
that produces the highest results then
they'll use that result no no these are
these are big issues in the state of
Washington recently an audit was done
for one of the testing laboratories and
they actually found a sticky note that
was written by one of the producer
the cannabis product producers who
submitted a sample and I'll not stick
you know they requested a certain level
of THC and their samples and if they did
not meet that level they requested that
they send more samples so this is a bit
of an issue but hopefully things are
getting better and States are now
putting in place mystery shoppers so the
state will submit five different a one
sample to five different laboratories
and they will see if those laboratories
get the same result if one laboratory
does not then they're flagged also
metrics are being kept in some states so
if one laboratory continually passes a
sample through that have very very high
cannabinoid contents and the other
testing laboratories in the state they
all fall within a certain range and then
then it's flagged also states are
starting to perform surprise audits of
these cannabis testing laboratories so
we're moving forward but in some states
we're not quite there yet this is an
example of a certificate of analysis
that is provided by a cannabis testing
laboratory you can see the name of the
sample which is Tennessee grown hemp you
can see the potency the CBD potency and
total potency there's also an example of
the chromatogram and we can also see
what the sample looks like what I like
about this CFA is that it provides a QR
code and that QR code provides
traceability and with traceability we're
trying to minimize tampering
so with traceability we're able to see
from the cultivation point all the way
to what happens or how that sample is
tested how many times that sample is
tested
and then where that sample goes after
testing so in some states customers do
have access to these QR codes or
traceability codes so they can see when
the sample was tested how it was tested
what the results were so at the moment
states are trying to adopt the seed to
sale traceability software in summary
error can occur at every step of the
testing process it can occur during
sampling it can occur while the samples
being tested but it can also occur after
the sample has been tested and and that
that's one of the most dramatic errors
and the cannabis industry is really
consumer driven and consumer feedback on
the products that are out there on the
market is absolutely essential if a
consumer is not having a good experience
of one of these products they need to
communicate that information to this the
dispensary and if the dispensary is
getting the same feedback from several
customers there there's likely an issue
so our job as scientists is to be aware
of these issues and to minimize them as
much as possible so with that I will
turn it back to Judy and see if we have
any questions Thank You Katherine for
that informative presentation we will
now start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for let's get started our first question
is what can consumers do to find out if
the products they purchased are
accurately labeled testing in the
laboratory is quite expensive so I would
read
that consumers purchase the the testing
kits which is basically a color metric
test they'll get an idea of what that
sample contains or an estimate of what
the sample contains and that's probably
what I would recommend because it's very
easy and it's very fast fast way to to
kind of get an estimate of what that
simple
it contains great thank you where can I
learn how to perform HPLC and roughly
how much do the instruments cost I well
H PLC's are quite expensive they are
typically more than $50,000 which is why
they're used in analytical testing
laboratories but if you're interested in
learning about HPLC in general or how to
perform HPLC there's a lot of
information on the Internet
you can also go to the waters web site
or other manufacturers websites where
they provide basic instruction on HPLC
but if you want to be immersed and learn
hands-on then you'll probably have to go
to a training event which which we do
offer here at the waters corporation
thank you we have time for one more
question
you mentioned lab accreditation can you
elaborate on the accreditation process
so I mentioned lab accreditation when I
was talking about proficiency testing
accreditation means that the laboratory
has been certified as technically
competent and that means the lab is able
to produce precise and accurate testing
and calibration data so many
laboratories that are testing cannabis
have ISO 17025 accreditation and
typically this involves having a third
party come out and audit that lab they
look at the practices that are performed
they look at the documentation and they
provide
certification one thing that I would say
to producers who are submitting samples
to laboratories I encourage you to look
for laboratories that do have this
accreditation certificate some labs say
that they work under ISO standards but
that doesn't mean that they've actually
been accredited so uh so that that's
what happens with the accreditation
process thank you I'd like to once again
thank Katherine Layton for her
presentation I'd also like to thank lab
roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through June 29th 2018 you'll receive an
email from lab roots letting you know in
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that was all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye